Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a biweekly podcast from the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. Before we dive into our conversation, I want to remind you that we love to hear from you. If you have any comments, questions, or ideas for us, please email me at K-Luna at APA.org. That's K-L-U-N-A-A-A-D-R. Now on to the conversation. The spaces we are in every day influence our mood and well-being, whether we're aware of it or not. Creating spaces to make us feel our best is a hot topic in community planning in the office and on HGTV.
您好，欢迎收听美国心理学会（APA）的双周播客《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳（Caitlin Luna）。在开始对话之前，我想提醒大家，我们非常乐意听到您的反馈。如果您有任何意见、问题或想法，请发送电子邮件至 K-Luna@APA.org。即 K-L-U-N-A@APA.org。现在，让我们进入正题。无论我们是否意识到，我们每天所处的空间都会影响我们的情绪和幸福感。创造让我们感觉良好的空间，是社区规划、办公室设计以及 HGTV 节目中的热门话题。
Here to talk about designing spaces to optimize well-being is APA fellow Dr. Sally Augustine, an environmental psychologist who is a principal at Design with Science, a design consultation firm. Welcome, Dr. Augustine. Nice to be here. So the start of 2019 brought us the Marie Kondo effect is what I'll be calling it. She's the famous Japanese professional organizer who's show on Netflix. Netflix called Tidying Up has been wildly popular. So Americans seem hungry for this type of program to show us how to declutter our lives and our homes. And as a design psychologist, what are
今天，我们邀请到 APA 研究员、环境心理学家萨莉·奥古斯丁（Dr. Sally Augustine）博士，她是一家名为“科学设计”（Design with Science）的设计咨询公司的负责人，来谈谈如何通过设计空间来优化幸福感。欢迎您，奥古斯丁博士。很高兴来到这里。2019 年伊始，我们迎来了所谓的“近藤麻理惠效应”。她是著名的日本专业整理师，她在 Netflix 上的节目《怦然心动的人生整理魔法》（Tidying Up）非常受欢迎。美国人似乎渴望这类节目来教我们如何清理生活和家庭。作为一名设计心理学家，您对这个节目的反响有何看法？
your thoughts on the response to the show? I think the response to the show indicates how burdened so many of us are by all the things in our physical environment. We have books, we have Chachis, we have all sorts of stuff that surround us and all those materials create an environment that's really very complex visually and when we're in a complicated visual environment, we feel stress. So I think the success of the Marie Kondo show indicates that people really, really need to tone back all the visual activity in the spaces that are around them. and they need to create a space that has about the same number of colors, shapes, patterns, et cetera, as they're likely to find in an interior designed by Frank Lloyd Wright.
我认为这个节目的反响表明，我们许多人都被物质环境中的各种物品所累。我们有书、有小摆件，周围充斥着各种各样的东西，所有这些材料创造了一个视觉上非常复杂的环境。当我们处于复杂的视觉环境中时，会感到压力。因此，我认为近藤麻理惠节目的成功表明，人们确实非常需要减少周围空间中的视觉干扰。他们需要创造一个空间，其颜色、形状、图案等的数量，大约相当于弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特（Frank Lloyd Wright）设计的室内空间。
Can you explain more why clutter makes us stressed? I mean, it seems like Americans tend to have too much stuff, and it makes us stressed. But giving it away and getting rid of it is difficult. So can you talk about why clutter, though, is still stressful for us? Clutter is stressful for us because whether you realize it or not, you're always surveying the environment around you. This is because our mental apparatus evolved millennia ago and we're still using the same sort of brain systems to assess our world now that we did in the past. So when we were young as a species, it was very important for us to be continually looking around. our world, making sure that nothing that found us tasty, was approaching. And when there's more
您能详细解释一下为什么杂乱会让我们感到压力吗？我的意思是，美国人似乎往往拥有太多的东西，这让我们感到压力。但要舍弃和清理它们却很难。所以，您能谈谈为什么杂乱对我们来说仍然是有压力的吗？杂乱之所以让我们感到压力，是因为无论你是否意识到，你总是在审视周围的环境。这是因为我们的心理机制是在几千年前进化而来的，我们现在评估世界所使用的脑系统与过去并无二致。因此，当我们作为一个物种还处于早期阶段时，不断环顾四周以确保没有捕食者靠近是非常重要的。而当周围的视觉信息过多时，
going on around us visually, it's harder to spot tigers, whatever, that might be lurking out there. So when we're in a space that's more complex visually, we get stressed out. Yeah, that's really interesting how it goes back so much further than just the current day, how it's a part of our biology. Yeah, it really is intriguing to think about all the vestiges of our primordial selves, if you will, that continue to be important in our world. And can you talk about your work you do at Design with Science? How did you get started? And what type of clients do you work with? Well, I have an MBA as well as a PhD. And I, I got involved in retail design projects as the sort of management type, if you will, when I
就更难发现可能潜伏在那里的老虎或其他危险。所以，当我们处于视觉上更复杂的空间时，就会感到压力。是的，这确实很有趣，它不仅关乎当下，更是我们生物学的一部分。是的，想到我们原始自我的残余在当今世界依然重要，确实非常引人入胜。您能谈谈您在“科学设计”公司的工作吗？您是如何开始的？您与什么样的客户合作？嗯，我既有工商管理硕士（MBA）学位，也有博士学位。我从商学院毕业后，以管理者的身份参与了零售设计项目，
graduated from business school and was intrigued by how the physical environment in stores influence what people think and behave. That led me to go back to school to study environmental psychology and led me to my current practice where I work with people who are designing places or objects or services. And I make recommendations based on environmental psych research that make desired activities, outcomes, et cetera, more likely. So I will make suggestions about what colors, walls should be painted in order to enhance creative performance in a space or how ceiling heights come into play, how the textures we feel
并对物理环境如何影响人们的思维和行为产生了浓厚兴趣。这促使我回到学校攻读环境心理学，并引导我走上了现在的职业道路。我与那些设计场所、产品或服务的人合作，并根据环境心理学研究提出建议，使预期的活动、结果等更有可能实现。因此，我会就墙壁应该涂什么颜色来增强空间内的创造性表现，或者天花板高度如何发挥作用，以及我们感受到的纹理如何影响我们的生活提出建议。
make a difference in our lives. And I work with people all over the world to get environmental psych research out of all sorts of journals and into the world where it can make a difference in people's lives. It seems like more businesses and people are interested in designing good spaces today. Is that true or is that just, is it always been an interest? I think at one level, it's always been an interest, you know, since the, you know, first, you know, person tried to sell something to some other person, you know, they've been motivated to create an environment conducive to that. I have seen increased attention to applying environmental psychology in the last few years because people are becoming more aware that there is a science that can be used to design environments and make particular
我与世界各地的人们合作，将各种期刊中的环境心理学研究应用到现实世界中，从而改善人们的生活。似乎现在有更多的企业和个人对设计良好的空间感兴趣。这是真的吗？还是说这一直都是人们关注的焦点？我认为在某种程度上，这一直都是人们关注的焦点。你知道，自从第一个人试图向另一个人推销东西开始，他们就有动力去创造一个有利于销售的环境。在过去几年里，我看到人们对应用环境心理学的关注度有所提高，因为人们越来越意识到，有一门科学可以用来设计环境，并使特定的结果和情况更有可能发生。
outcomes and situations more likely. And now I want to get into more of the design details, how they influence us. Can you talk about how our motions are influenced by colors, patterns, lighting, and texture? Sure. I'll start with color. because this is what I'm asked about most frequently. Color has three attributes. There's hue, which is the name we give to a collection of wavelengths, and there's also saturation and brightness. Saturation is how true a color is.
现在我想深入探讨一下设计细节，以及它们是如何影响我们的。您能谈谈我们的情绪是如何受到颜色、图案、照明和纹理影响的吗？当然。我先从颜色说起，因为这是我被问到最多的问题。颜色有三个属性：色相（Hue），即我们给一组波长起的名称；还有饱和度（Saturation）和亮度（Brightness）。饱和度是指颜色的纯度。
So like a khaki green is less saturated than a kelly green. You also might think of saturation as how much. gray there is in a color with less saturated colors having a more gray component to them. And brightness is, you know, surprisingly enough exactly what it sounds like. It's really, you could think of it as how much white there is mixed into a color. So colors that are not very saturated, but are relatively bright, relax us. So like a sage green that has lots of white mixed into it, so it's a light color. Well, we would find relaxing to look at a
比如，卡其绿的饱和度就比亮绿色低。你也可以把饱和度理解为颜色中灰色成分的多少，饱和度越低的颜色，灰色成分越多。而亮度，正如其名，你可以把它理解为颜色中混合了多少白色。所以，饱和度不高但相对明亮的颜色会让我们放松。比如鼠尾草绿，它混合了大量的白色，所以是一种浅色。我们会觉得看着这样的颜色很放松，
color like that, where a color that is more saturated but not as bright, something like say a Kelly green, well, we find that really energizing to experience. But there are a couple
而饱和度较高但亮度较低的颜色，比如亮绿色，我们则会觉得它非常令人振奋。但有几种色调对我们有非常特殊的影响。看到各种不同的绿色，更有可能让我们进行创造性思考。而看到红色，例如，会降低我们的分析表现。真的吗？这只是开始。还有很多其他有趣的研究我们可以谈谈。例如，当人们坐在某种垫子上时，你可以把它看作是一种触觉体验，
hues that have very particular effects on us. Seeing all sorts of different greens makes it more likely that we'll think creatively. And seeing Reds, for example, degrades are analytical performance. Really? Just for starters. And there's a lot of other interesting research that we can talk about. For example, when people are sitting on a cushion of some sort, you can think of that
他们讨价还价的意愿会比坐在较硬的表面上时更低。当我们闻到特定的气味时，即使它们非常微妙，且我们已经接触了很长时间，它们也会对我们的思维产生重大影响。例如，当我们闻到薰衣草味时，我们更有可能信任身边的人；而闻到柠檬味则可能增强我们的认知表现。
as a haptic experience, a touch-based experience. They are less likely to drive us hard a bargain as when they're sitting on a harder surface. When we smell a particular sense, even if they're very subtle and we've been being exposed to them for, and we've been exposed to them for a long time, well, they have significant influences on what goes on in our heads. For example, when we smell lavender, we are more likely to trust those who are nearby, and smelling lemon is likely to enhance our cognitive performance.
所以，我们可以逐一探讨各种感官，看看不同的刺激如何影响我们的思维和行为。我们还可以考虑更多的社会心理因素，比如人类对隐私的需求，对物理环境的控制需求。基本上，你周围所能看到、听到、感觉到的一切，都会对你的大脑产生某种影响。那么图案呢？有没有什么特定的图案比其他图案更让人感到刺眼或不安？或者更让人感到舒缓？嗯，思考图案很有趣，因为它们是由不同的形状、颜色和线条类型组成的。在为你的生活空间选择图案时，一个非常重要的考虑因素是曲线与直线的相对数量。没有哪个图案或空间是完全由曲线构成的，那看起来像卡通片；也不是完全由直线构成的。一个全是直线的空间会让你觉得——嗯，那就像恐怖电影里可怕的宇宙飞船内部。所以，当我们接触到相对较多的曲线时，我们会认为空间更舒适；
So, you know, we can work our way through the senses one by one and see how various different stimuli influence how we think and behave. And we can also think about more psychosocial type factors such as, you know, humans need for privacy, their need for control over their physical environment. You know, basically everything you can see here, feel, et cetera, around you has some influence on what goes on in your brain. What about patterns? Are there any particular patterns that are more, you may be jarring or upsetting than other patterns? or more soothing? Well, it's interesting to think about patterns because, you know, they're composed of different
而当我们主要看到直线（例如直角）时，效率的想法就会浮现。所以，这些线条以及颜色等，在选择图案时都是重要的考量因素。是的，这一切都在我们几乎没有意识到的情况下发生，这真的很迷人。还有照明，我的意思是，例如，我不喜欢荧光灯，我在办公室里用台灯。所以照明对我来说是一个重要的组成部分。您能谈谈它对其他人意味着什么，什么样的照明对人们有益，什么样的照明对人们来说比较困难吗？当然。在考虑照明时，重要的是要与人们试图在空间中完成的任务或想要获得的体验相一致。
shapes and colors and types of lines and things like that. And something that's really significant to consider when you're choosing a pattern for a place in your life is the relative number of curving lines versus the number of straight lines. And no pattern or place is entirely curvilinear. I mean, that seems like a cartoon. Or entirely rectilinear. A place that's all rectilinear makes you, well, that's like an awful spaceship horror movie type interior. So when we're exposed to relatively more curvy lines, we think a space is more
所以，如果你想放松或进行创造性思考，暖光效果会很好。这对人们来说并不奇怪，因为当我们想放松、与人聚会并享受美好时光时，我们会做什么？我们倾向于点燃火堆，点上蜡烛，所有这些都会产生暖光。但冷光也有其用武之地。当你试图进行一些更具分析性的工作时，冷光会更好。此外，当你需要振作起来，给自己增加能量时，也需要冷光。所以，如果你在锻炼，你想要打开锻炼空间里那些装有冷色调灯泡的灯。
comfortable where when we're seeing mainly rectilinear lines, straight lines, meaning at right angles, for example, well, thoughts of efficiency come to mind. So, you know, these sorts of lines along with color, et cetera, are important considerations when patterns are being selected. Yeah, it's so fascinating that this is all happening really without us being cognizant of it, I think, for the most part. And lighting, too. I mean, for example, I like to don't really like fluorescent lighting and I use a lamp in my office. So lighting is an important component to me. Can you talk about what it means to other people and what lighting is beneficial, what lighting is difficult for people? Sure. When we're thinking about lighting, it's really important to align with whatever people are trying to accomplish
那么声音在这一切中扮演什么角色呢？对有些人来说，嘈杂的空间可能非常令人恼火，但对另一些人来说，他们可能在嘈杂的环境中表现得更好。声音有很多主观因素。当我们对制造噪音的人感觉更积极，或者噪音本身对我们有良好的联想时，我们就不太容易被它激怒。但总的来说，在工作场所等环境中，我们会被谈话所干扰，尤其是那些似乎与我们的生活有某种关联的谈话。但我们也不希望处于完全寂静的空间中。我的意思是，
or what sort of experience people are trying to have in a space. So if you want to relax or think creatively, a warmer light can really work out well. And this would be no surprise to people because, you know, what do we do when we want to relax and hang out with people and have a good time? We tend to light a fire and, you know, bring out the candles, all of which produce warm light. But there's a time for cooler light. And cooler light is good when you're trying to do something a little more analytical. And also, you're also. Also, when you need to revere yourself up and give yourself a boost of energy. So, you know, if you are trying to work out, you want to turn on the lamps in, you know, whatever space you're working out in that have the cooler colored light bulbs in them.
首先，在日常生活中创造那样的空间是不可能的。而且，这对我们来说太奇怪了。那不是我们的耳朵和大脑进化的环境。我们度过早期岁月的空间并不是寂静的，总是有一些声音。一些相对较新的研究表明，听到自然的声音，比如你在一个美好的春日里在草地上可能听到的那种声音，对我们的认知是有恢复作用的。所以，如果我们因为做需要专注的工作而感到精神疲惫，听到轻轻的树叶沙沙声或潺潺的溪水声等，
And what about how to sound play into all this? So noisy spaces for some people can be really aggravating, but for other people, they can really thrive in a noisy environment. Sound has a lot of subjective elements to it. When we feel more positive about the people making the noise or the noise itself has good associations to us, we're less likely to be aggravated by it. But generally, we are distracted in workplaces and things like that. by conversations and particularly conversations that seem like they might have some relevance to our life. But we also never want to be in a space that's completely silent. I mean, you know,
我们可以恢复心理处理能力，压力也会减轻。我想回到您之前谈到的气味，以及它有多重要。大家都知道气味在记忆回溯中起着重要作用，但气味如何帮助我们记住要保持创造力呢？您提到柠檬起着重要作用，能详细说明一下吗？当然。柠檬与增强创造性表现有关。但有两种不同但相关的体验。有些体验似乎是普遍的，比如我刚才提到的薰衣草与信任、柠檬与认知表现之间的联系。但还有一些是每个人独有的。所以，如果你在祖母的门廊上与家人进行过愉快的交谈，而你的祖母种植了各种各样的金银花，它们环绕着那个门廊，那么你对金银花的香味就会有各种各样对你和你的家人来说独一无二的积极联想。所以，我们需要考虑对气味的普遍反应，以及更具个人特质的反应。有没有什么气味可以帮助我们更好地学习？
first of all, it's impossible to create a space like that in everyday life. But also, that's just plain weird to us. That isn't where our ears and, you know, brains developed. You know, the spaces where we spent our early days, you know, wasn't, wasn't silent. There was always a little bit going on. And some interesting recent research indicate, or relatively recent research, indicates that hearing nature sounds, the sorts of sounds that you might hear in like a meadow on a lovely spring day, well, that is cognitively restorative to us. So, you know, if we've become mentally mentally exhausted doing work that requires concentration or focus, if we hear sounds like gently rustling leaves or a burbling brook, etc.
是的，通常像花香这样被认为令人愉悦并能提升情绪的气味，在学习新材料时闻起来会很好。任何能提升我们情绪的东西，都会使我们更有可能获得富有成效的教育体验，与他人相处融洽等。家具应该如何摆放才能营造出某种感觉？这可能很难回答，因为这是一个非常广泛的问题，但如果你想营造舒适感，该如何摆放家具？如果你想营造一个更严肃的办公环境，又该如何摆放家具？
We can restock our mental processing power and also, you know, we become a little less stressed. And I want to go back to what you talked about before about scent and how important that is. I mean, it's pretty widely known that scent plays an important. part of memory recall, but how can sent be used to help us remember to be creative? And you said lemons play an important role. Can you elaborate on that a little bit more? Sure. Lemon is linked to enhanced creative performance. But there are two sorts of different related experiences. There are some that seem pretty universal, like the ones I was talking about
当然。在摆放家具时，你需要考虑空间里会发生什么，以及谁会在那里。例如，我们都有过走进教室发现椅子围成一圈的经历，或者坐在圆桌旁，每个人都可以很容易地与他人进行眼神交流。当人们可以与他人进行眼神交流时，通常更有可能参与对话等。
with lavender and trust and lemon and cognitive performance. But there are others that are unique to each individual. So, you know, if you had lovely conversations with family members on your grandmother's front porch and your grandmother cultivated all sorts of different kinds of honeysuckles or whatever or honeysuckle plants and they, you know, surrounded that porch, you'll have all sorts of positive associations to the scent of honeysuckle that are unique, you know, to you and your family. So, you know, we need to think about more general responses to sense as also, as well as more idiosyncratic ones. Is there a scent that can help us learn better?
但眼神交流也有一些文化成分。我们这些在西方长大的人，比在世界其他地方长大的人更倾向于进行并保持眼神交流。因此，如果你要创造一个来自多种文化背景的人都可能在场的空间，在桌子中间放一个低矮的焦点，比如花艺，是一个好主意，当人们需要从眼神交流中休息一下时，可以优雅地转移视线。此外，在摆放家具时，我们还必须考虑人际空间等因素。
Yeah, generally a scent such as a floral scent that is likely to be perceived as pleasant and boost our mood would be a good sort of odor to smell while we're learning new material. You know, anything that will boost our mood makes it more likely that we'll have. productive educational experiences, get along with others, etc. And how can a furniture be arranged to create a certain feel? I mean, this might be difficult because it's such a broad question, but if you're trying to create comfort, how can you arrange furniture? If you're trying to create more of an serious office environment, how can you arrange furniture?
你知道，我们中的一些人，基于我们的文化、个性等，喜欢比其他人更靠近彼此。此外，个性也会影响人们偏好的座位类型。举个例子，像我这样外向的人，比内向的人更愿意与他人共用一张沙发。因此，家具的选择和在区域内的摆放位置涉及很多因素。是的，确实如此。而且，从我自己的家居装饰经验来看，如何让空间看起来更大可能是一个挑战。我的意思是，你可以用镜子来帮助让空间变大吗？
Sure. When you're arranging furniture, you need to think about what's going to happen in the space and who's going to be there. For example, we've all had the experience of walking into a classroom and finding the chairs arranged in a circle, for example, or sitting at a roundish table where everybody can make a ready eye contact with each other. People generally are more likely to participate in a conversation, et cetera, when they can make eye contact with others.
是的，让空间看起来更大的最直接的方法之一就是把墙壁漆成浅色。浅色的墙壁看起来比实际距离要远一点，这通常是一件好事。我们很少有人住在房间大到让我们觉得空旷的房子里或工作环境中。没错。是的，大多数时候你都在试图让它看起来更大。所以把天花板漆成深色可能不是一个好主意，因为它可能会
but there are some cultural components to eye contact. And those of us who are raised in the West are a lot more into making eye contact and maintaining it than people who have grown up in other parts of the world. So if you're creating a space where people from many cultures are likely to be present, it can be a good idea to have some sort of low, like focal point, like flower arrangement in the middle of a table that people can gracefully divert their gaze to when they need an eye contact break from others. Also, we have to think about things like interpersonal spaces when we're arranging furniture.
让你觉得——没错，如果你把天花板漆成深色，它似乎会压下来，这真的会让人感到压抑。我前段时间看了一部纪录片叫《天空中的城市》（City in the Sky），讲的是机场是如何设计的，让人们无需标志就能找到路，这很迷人，因为很多线索都是潜意识和微妙的，但它们确实有效。它们引导人们朝着特定的方向前进。您能谈谈这是如何运作的吗？你知道，人类有一种倾向，总是通过周围的世界来观察，他们也渴望以特定的方式穿过空间。例如，我们这些在西方的人，特别是那些在道路右侧行驶的人，
You know, some of us, based on our culture, personality, et cetera, like to be closer to each other than others do. Also, personality influences the sorts of seats. people prefer, just as an example. People like me who are extroverted are a lot more positive about sharing a sofa, for example, with others than people who are introverted. So there are a lot of factors that go into furniture selection and where furniture is placed in an area. Yeah, it does really sound like it. And, you know, going from my own experience of home decorating, and it can be a challenge with how to make the space appear larger. I mean, you can use mirrors maybe to help. make a space larger?
倾向于向右走。除非有东西引导我们，否则我们倾向于保持直线前进。我们倾向于留在相同的地面材料上。所以如果我们走在铺了地毯的路径上，除非有充分的理由，否则我们不太可能离开那个地毯表面。这种人们的倾向可以用来设计环境，使他们更有可能前往一个空间或另一个空间。还有其他因素也会发挥作用。
Yeah, I mean, you know, one of the most straightforward ways to make a space seem larger is to paint the walls a lighter color. Walls that are a lighter color seem a little further away than they actually are, which is often a good thing. Very few of us live in homes or work in environments where the rooms are too big for us. Right. Yeah, most of the time you're trying to make it look bigger. but so it's probably not a good idea to paint the ceiling a dark color because it can probably
比如我们倾向于走向明亮的灯光或窗户。这是环境如何让人们朝着预期的目标不断前进的另一个例子。是的，想到你在穿过空间时所接收到的所有帮助你找到方向的线索，即寻路，这真的很迷人。是的，人类真的很酷。我们的大脑真的很奇妙。是的，它们确实如此。
make it feel like your right if you paint the ceiling a dark color it does seem to move down on you that can really get to feeling oppressive so i watched this documentary a while ago called city in the sky about how airports design or design in such a way that allows people to find their way without signs and it's fascinating because a lot of these cute were all subconscious and subtle, but they worked. They directed people in a specific direction. So you talk about how that works. You know, humans have this tendency to always be looking through the world around them, and they also desire to move through spaces in particular ways. For example, those of us in the West, particularly who drive on the same side of the road that we do in
关于开放式办公室概念已经过时且对许多人来说并不奏效的讨论很多。那么，对于想要创造一个既能促进协作和创造力，又能提供隐私的办公空间的客户，您有什么建议？当然。开放式办公室正在从人们传统认为的开放式办公室演变为所谓的“基于活动的办公场所”（activity-based workplace）。
America tend to, you know, travel, you know, towards the right. We tend to keep going in a straight line unless there's something that diverts us. We tend to stay on the same material underfoot. So if we're walking on a carpeted path, a carpeted surface, we're unlikely to leave that carpeted surface unless we have a good reason to do so. And this kind of proclivity, if you will, among people can be used to design environments that make it more likely they'll travel to one space or another. There's other things that come into play as well.
在基于活动的办公场所中，人们可以在不同时间使用一系列不同类型的空间。基于活动的办公场所似乎对用户非常有效，因为当人们做的事情不需要那么多的专注力时，他们可以待在像工作休息室或咖啡区这样的地方。但当他们真正需要专注时，无论是独自一人还是与他人一起，他们可以移动到另一种空间。所以，在环境方面拥有灵活性，以及能够控制我们在哪里工作，对我们的表现和情绪都非常有益。所以，一切美好的事物都源于控制感。因此，拥有一个混合空间，既有一些你可以拥有隐私的地方，也有这些用于协作的开放区域，可能是最好的建议。
Like we tend to walk towards bright lights or a window. This is another example of the way an environment can keep people moving. moving forward to a desired goal. Yeah, that's really, it's really fascinating just to think about all the things you just do take in as you're, you know, walking through a space that help you find your way, the wayfinding. Yeah, people are really cool. Our brains are really interesting. Yeah, they certainly are.
是的，这就是基于活动的办公场所的真正含义。它是多种不同类型的迷你工作环境组合成一个企业或组织区域。我想回到您在开头谈到的关于空间如何设计以增加销售额的概念。那么，商店是否以特定的方式设置来激励我们购买？是的。零售环境中发生的所有事情都会鼓励人们进行购买。例如，颜色选择可以是推动销售的重要方式。如果你有更多冲动购买类型的商品，你会让环境变得更有活力；如果需要考虑才能在现有商品中进行选择，
There's been a lot of talk about the open office concept being dead and really not working out for a lot of people. So what advice do you have for clients about creating an office space that allows for collaboration, creativity? but also also allows for privacy? Sure. The open office is really evolving from what people classically think of an open office to what's known as an activity-based workplace.
你就会希望环境不那么有活力。所有这些归根结底都是要考虑你面对的是什么样的购物者。有些人有时在购物时更注重实用性。他们必须尽快买到牛奶和面包，无论出于什么原因离开商店。而另一些人则是休闲型购物者。你知道，他们周六下午和朋友们一起出来。所以，在创造工作环境时，你需要考虑购物者及其目标。我的意思是，在设计零售环境时，你需要考虑购物者及其目标。为什么通常在过道尽头会有那些冲动购买的商品？很多时候，在杂货店，你会看到糖果；在像 Bed Bath and Beyond 这样的商店，你会看到一堆你可能不需要的小玩意。
And in an activity-based workplace, there are a range of different sorts of spaces that people can use at different times. And activity-based workplaces really seem to work out, if you don't mind the pun, pretty well for users because when people are doing something that doesn't require quite as much, concentration or focus, they can hang out in a place like a sort of at-work lounge or coffee area, for example. But when they really need to concentrate, either alone or with others, they can move to another sort of space. So, you know, having flexibility in terms of
也许你需要，但你是在排队时看到它们的。这只是为了潜意识地驱使人们在去收银台之前进行那些最后一分钟的购买吗？嗯，那些端架（N-CAPs）或收银台展示架引起了人们对这些物品的注意，并以其他方式可能不会发生的方式使它们变得非常相关。你知道，如果你在商店里，你可能不会走完整个过道，甚至不会转进过道。但是，你通常无法避免走过端架，而且你肯定必须经过某种收银区才能离开商店。所以，在这些区域放置冲动型购买商品会让购物者
the environments available and the ability to control where we work is great for our performance, our mood. So all things good flow out of control. So having a hybrid, if you will, of like some places where you can have your privacy, but you can also have these open areas for collaboration is probably the best suggestion. Yeah. And that's what an activity-based workplace really is. It's a variety of different sorts of mini work environments all combined into one corporate or organizational area. And I want to go back to a concept you talked about in the beginning about how space can be designed to increase sales. So are stores set up in a particular way to motivate us to buy? Yeah. There's all sorts of things that happen in retail.
注意到它们，特别是在结账区，这让他们有机会在排队等待付款时考虑这些物品。设计是城市规划中的一个大概念，所以城市规划者正在转向混合用途开发风格，简单描述一下，你有一个大型建筑，底层有餐厅、商店、健身房，顶层有公寓。这是规划者为了解决人们感到的孤独和孤立而做出的有意识的努力吗？孤独和孤立，以及对抗孤独和孤立，是环境心理学家一直在思考的话题。
environments that encourage people to make purchases. For example, you know, color selection can be an important way to drive sales. You know, if you've got more of an impulse purchase type good, you make an environment a little more energizing if consideration. is required to select among goods available. You want the environment to be a little less energizing, for example. And all this gets down to really thinking about what sort of shopper you're dealing with. Some people are at particular points in time much more utilitarian focused in their shopping.
创造人们需要经过或路过的空间，在一定程度上可以帮助对抗孤独感。所以，它们在我们的城市和其他地方被更频繁地实施。这是一个新概念，还是我们上个世纪看到的规划社区概念的一种重组？在许多方面，它是更古老事物的一种重组。几百年前，人们通常真的住在商店或作坊的楼上。因此，将更多的商业区与更多的住宅区结合起来，对我们来说长期以来一直很重要。
They have to buy milk and bread as quickly as possible. possible, get out of the store for whatever reason. And other people are more recreational type shoppers. You know, they're out on a Saturday afternoon with their friends. So, you know, you need to consider the shoppers and what their goals are when you're creating a work environment. I mean, you need to consider the shoppers and their goals when you're designing a retail environment. Is there a reason why typically at the end of the aisle there's those impulse-like purchases? A lot of times, you know, at the grocery stores, you see candy at a store like Bad Bath and Beyond, you see a bunch of little knick-knacks you probably don't need.
例如，它更具资源效率，而且可以简化生活。是的，现在似乎有一种趋势是将人们带入一个空间，而我认为过去人们更倾向于在郊区社区拥有更多的空间，拥有更大的房子。但现在人们想要，特别是在像华盛顿特区这样的城市，人们有一种趋势，想要再次被带入那些城市中心。或者即使你在另一个小社区，你仍然想要一个可以像城镇广场那样的区域。没错。人们是社会性的，他们需要在选择时有机会与他人互动。而且，随着我们开发更多的工具，我们需要花更少的时间做一些我们可能称之为“生活任务”的事情，
Maybe you do, but you see them as you're waiting in line. Is that just to subconsciously drive people to, you know, make those last-minute purchases before they go to the register? Well, those sorts of N-CAPs or at-register displays bring people, attention to those objects and make them really pertinent in ways that might not otherwise be the case. You know, if you're in a store, you might not travel down an entire aisle or even turn down an aisle. But, you know, often you can't help but walk by the NCAP and you certainly, you know, have to pass through some sort of, you know, register area in order. to leave the store. So, you know, placing impulse-type purchases in these areas makes shoppers
而这些任务在过去是必须的。所以，几十年前，洗衣服是一个困难得多的过程。现在，我们许多人可以使用机器，这释放了大量的时间，我们可以从事其他对我们有意义的活动。而这些活动通常以某种方式涉及其他人。在您的领域，对于您在城市设计和规划中看到的趋势持什么态度？它们成功了吗？还是说是否成功还有待决定？我认为设计和设计研究总是在不断发展，我们总是在学习新事物，同时也面临着新的问题。
aware of them, you know, and particularly in a checkout area, it gives them the opportunity to consider these items while they're whiling away their time in line waiting to pay. And design is a big concept in urban planning, and so city planners and devaluing, are going toward a mixed use development type of style where you'll have just to describe it quickly you have a large building with say restaurant shops a gym on the bottom floors on the top floors you'll have condos or apartments is this a conscious effort by planners to try to address some of the loneliness and isolation people are feeling loneliness and isolation and countering loneliness and isolation are something that are topics that environmental psychologists think about you know all
所以我认为我们正在有效地处理孤独等问题，但我们仍然面临着与公平等相关的挑战。所以我们取得了一些进展，而其他问题依然存在。对于那些正在考虑设计家庭、办公空间等的人，您能总结出一些基本的整体设计禁忌吗？人们经常不考虑的一个因素是空间所传达的非语言信息。这些对于我们的压力水平、生活质量等非常重要。例如，我们喜欢住在一个能表达我们所珍视事物的家中。所以我们喜欢摆放一些能表明我们身份的物品，比如如果我们为自己的运动能力感到自豪，我们就是运动型的人；或者如果家庭对我们非常重要，我们就会展示与家庭相关的物品。
the time and creating spaces that will have other people in them that individuals need to pass through or by can help to some extent to counter feelings of loneliness. So, you know, they're being implemented more frequently in our cities and elsewhere. And this is a new concept or is this a retooling of sorts of the planned community concept we saw in the last century? In many ways, it's a retooling of something that's even older. Hundreds of years ago, people often literally lived above the shop or the workshop, etc. So combining more commercial areas with more residential areas is something that's It's been important to us for a long time.
此外，在我们的工作场所，例如，我们在那些表明雇主尊重我们以及我们为组织所做贡献的空间里工作得最好。你知道，雇佣组织可以通过给予人们对环境的控制权，以及真正倾听和理解员工的工作内容，从而使空间清晰地与个人和团队在一天中需要完成的任务相一致，来表达尊重。所以我认为我们总是需要考虑一个空间在象征意义上向用户传达了什么，并确保这些无声的对话是富有成效和积极的。是的，绝对是。您还做过关于室内植物如何让我们更有创造力的采访，我想顺便提一下。最后问您两个有趣的问题。
It's more resource efficient, for example, and just, you know, can streamline life. Yeah, it seems like there's a tendency now to bring people into a space, whereas I think in the past it was sort of like people wanting more space out in a suburban community, a larger home. But now it's people are wanting, especially in a city like Washington, D.C., where we are here, there's this tendency for people to want to be brought into those city centers again. Or even if you're out in a small another community, you still want an area that can be like the town square, if you will. Right. People are social and they need the opportunity to interact with others when they choose. And also, as we develop more tools, we need to spend less time doing some sort of, we might call them like, you know, life tasks. that we needed in the past. So in the, you know, years ago, decades ago, doing laundry was a much more difficult process.
在家里放一盆植物如何让你更有创造力？嗯，当你给家里增加绿叶植物时，你的压力水平会下降，你更有可能进行创造性思考。这可能涉及几个不同的因素。植物通常是绿色的，正如我们之前谈到的，看到绿色与增强创造性表现有关。此外，绿叶植物往往有弯曲的茎，
Now, many of us have access to machines, and that frees up lots of time where we can engage in other activities that are meaningful to us. And often those other activities involve other people one way or another. And in your world, what is the attitude about the trends you're seeing in urban design and planning? Are they, is it successful? Is it something that's still being decided if it's successful? I think design and design research is always evolving and we're always learning and new things and also being confronted by new issues.
这表明舒适，并在一定程度上让我们放松。所以，在空间里放几盆植物是个好主意。你不想放太多，你不想创造一个室内丛林，这会增加视觉复杂性，也就是我们之前谈到的。研究表明，绿叶植物的效果最好，而不是仙人掌之类的东西。所以，从心理学角度来看，保持一棵榕树或类似植物存活所付出的努力是值得的。
So I think we're effectively dealing with concerns such as loneliness, but we have challenges that remain that relate to things like equity. So we make some progress and other issues remain. And are there any basically overall design no-noes, if you will, that you could summarize for people if they're thinking about designing their home, an office space, that sort of thing? Something that people often don't consider are the nonverbal messages set by a space. And these are really important in terms of our stress levels, our quality of life, etc. For example, we like to live in a home that says the things about us that we value. So we like to have objects out that indicate like we're a sports person if we are proud of our ability to do different sports or we're concerned about our family if that's really important to us.
最后一个问题。您在年初接受了一次采访，谈到节日过后保留圣诞灯饰对我们的心理健康有好处。您能谈谈为什么会这样吗？当然。我认为当人们对圣诞灯饰等事物有积极的联想时，比如他们在过去几年的节日里有过很棒的体验，那么在他们觉得不想再看到它们之前保留这些灯饰，可以给个人带来心理上的提升。你知道，我们在环境心理学中揭示的基本故事的一部分是，人们需要忠于自己，
Also, in our workplace, for example, we do our best work in spaces that indicate that our employer respects us and the contribution we make to the organization. You know, an employing organization can indicate respect by doing things like giving people some control over there in environment and also really listening and understanding what employees do so that a space clearly aligns with what individuals and groups need to accomplish during the course of the day. So I think that we always need to be considering what a space is conveying symbolically, if you will, to users and making sure that those silent conversations are productive and positive. Yeah, absolutely. And you've also done interviews about how indoor plants can make us more creative. and I want to just to throw that in there. Two kind of last fun kind of questions for you.
忠于让他们感觉良好的事物，以及忠于他们的人性、人类属性。所以，如果你沉浸在节日气氛中，在冬天的早期，当白天很短、天气寒冷时看到它们，这可能会有所帮助。而且现在我们只是在谈论人们对圣诞灯饰可能有的联想，但你也可以考虑灯光的各种颜色如何影响人们的思维和行为。例如，如果很多灯发出金色的暖光，
So how does having a plant in your home make you more creative? Well, when you add green leafy plants to your home, your stress levels come down and you are more likely to think creatively. And there's probably several different factors that come into play. Plants are often green. as we were talking about before, green has been linked to, seeing the color green has been linked to enhanced creative performance. Also, green leafy plants tend to have curving stems,
那可以直接帮助人们放松、感到舒适、与他人相处融洽等，就像我们之前谈到的蜡烛一样。所以，如果你愿意，这给了我们一个多留几周的借口。如果它有助于你的幸福感，那是没问题的。非常感谢您加入我们，奥古斯丁博士。非常感谢您的时间。很高兴能与您共度这段时光。如果您是我们的老听众，或者刚开始收听我们的播客，请考虑在 iTunes 上给我们评分，如果有时间，请写一篇评论。我们将不胜感激。另外，正如我在
and that indicates comfort and relaxes us to a certain extent. So, you know, having a few plants in a space is a good idea. You don't want to add too many. You don't want to create an indoor jungle, if you will, that really increases the visual complexity, something that we were talking about earlier. And the research indicates that the best results are found with green leafy plants as opposed to things such as cactuses. So, you know, the effort that's required to keep a ficus or some sort of plant like that alive is worth it from a psychological perspective.
节目开头提到的，我们非常乐意直接听到您的反馈。所以如果您有任何问题、意见或想法要分享，请发送电子邮件至 K-Luna@APA.org。即 K-L-U-N-A@APA.org。《心理学谈话》是 APA 播客网络的一部分，该网络还包括其他很棒的播客，如《APA 期刊对话》（APA Journal's Dialogue），讨论新的心理学研究；以及《实践笔记》（Progress Notes），讨论心理学实践。您可以在 iTunes、Stitcher 或任何您获取播客的地方找到我们所有的播客。您也可以访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 收听更多剧集。我是美国心理学会的凯特琳·卢纳。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
And one last question for you. So you were interviewed for a sort of. story at the start of the year about how keeping Christmas lights up past the holidays, a little past the holidays, is good for our mental health. So you talk about why that is the case? Sure. I think that when people have positive associations to things such as Christmas lights, you know, they've had great experiences over the holidays in previous years, keeping the lights around for, you know, until they feel like they don't want them around anymore, can, give individuals a psychological boost. You know, part of the basic story that we're uncovering in environmental psychology is that people need to be true to themselves,
最后一个问题。今年年初，您曾接受过一次采访，谈到在节日过后的一段时间里保留圣诞彩灯对我们的心理健康有益。您能谈谈为什么会这样吗？当然。我认为，当人们对圣诞彩灯等事物有积极的联想时，比如他们往年过节时有过美好的经历，那么在他们觉得不想再看到这些彩灯之前，把它们留着可以给个人带来心理上的慰藉。你知道，我们在环境心理学中发现的基本事实之一是，人们需要忠于自己，
what makes them feel good, and to their humanness, their human attributes. And so having Christmas lights could be that if you're into the holiday spirit and seeing them in the, you know, early parts of the winter where the days are short and where it's cold, you know, it's cold and everything. Right. And right now we're just talking about the associations people may have to the Christmas lights, but you can also think about how the various colors of the lights may influence how people think and behave. For example, if lots of the lights are emitting a golden, warmer light,
忠于让自己感觉良好的事物，忠于自己的人性，即人类的特质。因此，如果你沉浸在节日气氛中，并且在白天短暂、寒冷且万物萧瑟的初冬时节看到这些彩灯，那么保留它们可能就是一种选择。没错。现在我们讨论的只是人们对圣诞彩灯可能产生的联想，但你也可以思考一下，彩灯的各种颜色是如何影响人们的思维和行为的。例如，如果许多彩灯发出金色的暖光，
You know, that can, you know, directly help people relax, feel comfortable, get along with others, et cetera, like we were talking about candles earlier. So this gives us a little excuse to me to keep them up a few weeks longer if you want. If you have, it's helping your well-being, it's okay. Thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Augustine. I really appreciate your time. I was glad to be able to spend the time with you. If you've been a longtime listener or are new to our podcast, please consider giving us a rating. in iTunes, and if you have time, write a review. We'd really appreciate it. Also, as I mentioned
你知道，这可以直接帮助人们放松、感到舒适、与他人和睦相处等等，就像我们之前谈到的蜡烛一样。所以，如果你想的话，这给了我们一个多留几周的借口。如果它有助于你的身心健康，那就没问题。非常感谢您参加我们的节目，奥古斯丁博士。非常感谢您抽出时间。很高兴能与您共度这段时光。如果您是我们的老听众，或者是第一次收听我们的播客，请考虑在 iTunes 上给我们评分，如果有时间，请写下评论。我们将不胜感激。另外，正如我提到的，
at the top of the show, we love to hear from you directly. So if you have any questions, comments, or ideas to share, please email me at K-Luna at APA.org. That's K-L-U-N-A-A-A-P-A-Dorg. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA Podcast Network, which includes other great podcasts like APA Journal's Dialogue about new psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology. You can find all our podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, speakingofpsychology.org, to listen to more episodes. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在节目开头，我们很乐意直接收到您的来信。因此，如果您有任何问题、意见或想法想要分享，请发送电子邮件至 K-Luna@APA.org。即 K-L-U-N-A@A-P-A.org。《心理学对话》是美国心理学会（APA）播客网络的一部分，该网络还包括其他优秀的播客，如讨论最新心理学研究的《APA 期刊对话》和关于心理学实践的《进度笔记》。您可以在 iTunes、Stitcher 或任何您获取播客的地方找到我们所有的节目。您也可以访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 收听更多剧集。我是美国心理学会的凯特琳·卢纳。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。